now I'm about to go buy some dinner for
my kids and yes I'm buying dinner and
I'm buying Pizza I'm tired a day a day
in the life of cardi B oh yes honey the
rapper gives a behind the scenes look of
her very relatable daily routine and
makes it clear in the caption this isn't
a cardi day it's a balconese day you
know her real name
first I started my day by checking my
phone I'm putting the water high and
brushing my teeth getting ready before
my kids notice I'm up because boom once
they knows I'm up they won't leave me
alone
here I am getting dressed because you're
putting on my shoes fighting with my son
and now we're about to go downstairs and
have some play time I love everything
about motherhood I'm doing lunch right
now usually I have somebody doing lunch
for me but everybody's on spring break
so yeah I got all the duties
and um feeding my kids before I head out
I'm taking culture with me to the gym
while my cousin take care of wavy
and I've been working out with lately
for two hours a day and then I stretch
for an hour party's always been an open
book about her body I really want to
explain to people how hard is the
process I feel like a lot of people look
at girls on Instagram and think like oh
they got the lapo done and it was so
easy and this is such a long hard
process but despite having surgery to
look her best she explains why she's
still gotta commit in the gym a lot of
people are so ignorant like why are you
working now you have a light bulb where
this is think of a cereal fat and the
cereal fat is the fat that surrounds
your organs that you cannot lipo that's
why you got to work it out and I want
tone thighs and you can buy some thighs
I feel good and then sometimes I feel
like nah you know what I'm saying like
your your skin is like more stretched
out now I'm stretching and um I want to
be able to be as flexible as I was
before I had my son but my real goal is
to be as stretchable and flexible as I
was when and I was a stripper but who
can't build
room in a day but can you one person
who's definitely inspired by the rapper
splits lizzo
the singer commented on Cardi's video I
need to get my splits together I'm like
damn this is a big deal now I'm about to
go buy some dinner for my kids and yes
I'm buying dinner and I'm buying Pizza
I'm tired
and um yeah you know having dinner
spending a little bit more time before I
head to the studios I just love my
babies and after a busy day mama has
earned herself a treat and now I'm at
the studio and Evan's not here so I'm
just gonna drink a little bit of wine
and just unwind myself thank you so much
let me know if you want more videos like
this bye I love ya
[Music]